oh yes here we are the last Jedi is out
gonna go ahead and give a spoiler
warning for this video these are real
comments in my Star Wars the last Jedi
review and spoiler review so there's
gonna be some spoilers stuff in here so
don't watch unless you've seen it to
help us out we have Supreme Leader Snoke
over here gonna read some comments are
we ready
boarded Snoke uh we were all ready for
Snoke to do something he just
disappeared it's a bold new direction
whatever let's get into I agree with the
review 100% especially about watching it
twice this is the best example of a film
you have to see twice yeah I was told by
people who had seen it a couple times or
like no the second time you watch it
it'll be this transcended experience and
I just didn't get that personally it was
a real bummer for me time does not fade
greatness one name one word to
illustrate the point
Ozymandias the quote goes my name is
Ozymandias king of kings look on my
works ye mighty and despair just google
it look into it there was a breaking bad
episode called Ozymandias to illustrate
that point hold on hey you have to
remember who told her that her parents
came from nothing ray I don't think ray
would lie to herself Ray's the one who
said it kylo Ren opened the conversation
and he said do you know who your parents
are have you always known say it and she
was like they were nobody so she's the
one who said it kylo Ren just like yeah
they were nobody but it was her who said
it so if kylo Ren's lying
well she's she I don't think so I do
here were the possibility that it will
be retcon when JJ Abrams comes back in
it's like no that's not what I planned
here's the real plan so I'm gonna go
back and undo that but for now I think
the intention by Rian Johnson was she
was telling the truth
Star Wars died after Disney bought Star
Wars well it certainly is a new
direction that's for sure and here's how
I see it we now have three Star Wars
trilogies one and incomplete trilogy but
still three Star Wars trilogies each one
is different than all the other ones the
original trilogy is not like the
prequels nor is it like the new wave of
Star Wars movies the new wave of Star
Wars movies is not actually like the old
trilogy nor is it like the prequels and
you have the prequels which are not like
the original Star Wars trilogy nor are
they like the new Star
movies and you have fans who ultimately
gravitate towards one trilogy and the
other ones don't line up with what they
like in Star Wars but it's because all
of them are different and that is why no
one hates Star Wars movies as much as
Star Wars fans because Star Wars fans
gravitate towards certain stories but
the other stories don't really line up
with the stories they like and so it all
feels different so they don't like those
when they're like these I would love to
see anyone out there who loves every
Star Wars movie I don't I've never seen
that we've all played it safe people
hate it on it now just tried something
new and still got hated absolutely ups
artists like these fanboys will never be
satisfied and I'm the only one who read
Goldilocks and the three bears when he
was a kid it's all about not being too
hot too cold just right if you don't
like this extreme it's okay to not like
this extreme but you're looking for
something in the middle so you can't be
like oh you didn't like this and now you
don't like this there's no pleasing
everybody there's some there's a perfect
zone in there that they should be
striving for that they're not just like
it's a world of extremes in Star Wars
that's like saying oh burning my hand is
really unpleasant and you freeze your
hand you're like that's unpleasant so I
was like there's no pleasing you it
doesn't really work like that extremes
can be disliked equally I felt the exact
same way about this movie as Jeremy that
doesn't tell I watched it a second time
once you accept the story that's in
front of you it's a way better
experience this movie is awesome tacular
whoa whoa whoa whoa did you just Knight
me with my own rating No H asleep
pretend that didn't happen let's get to
the point okay let's take Jar Jar Binks
for example Jar Jar Binks is so much
better when you realize that he's
actually a cartoon clown made for
children not supposed to be a compelling
good or funny character for adults I'm
not comparing the last Jedi to Jar Jar
Binks what I am saying is anything can
get better when you see it through that
line of reasoning when you validate it
and justify it from a certain angle just
stop leave the internet please no sorry
robot this is kind of what I do but feel
free do not come back you ought to be
game one with the force same as Luke did
in the empire strike
back are you saying Yoda became one with
the force and Luke became one with the
force in Empire Strikes Back
are you just saying Yoda became one with
the force in Empire Strikes Back you see
this is why grammar is so important kids
because without grammar without
punctuation it's impossible to decide
what's being said either way Yoda became
one with the force in Return of the Jedi
not Empire Strikes Back so there is that
wasn't it answered by Darth Vader had
his name I thought it was pretty blunt
in the way he invade heed the example
that was his purpose he was the invader
of the Jedi Order so that's why
Palpatine chose that name I don't know
if you're trolling me right now all
right that's what you tell yourself and
that gives you the reason I envy you for
having the reason to you you have a
reason that's that's awesome I would
love to feel that I don't but that'd be
great I completely disagree with your
rating outside of the casino crap but
your honesty get to like from me wait a
minute you mean someone who disagrees
with someone else about what they think
about Star Wars can be civil about it
online what winning rate came from
nothing but showed it Anakin Anakin was
conceived by the midi-chlorians making
him space Jesus so it's kind of
different actually very different
in fact so different we don't really
talk about it Jeremy Jones how about how
they had to arc turbo laser fire in
space holy I didn't even think
about that I didn't even realize that
that was they were firing the the first
orders firing on the rebel ships they
have to shoot up and arc the bolt down
and then it hits their ships because the
ships are so far away which wouldn't
happen in space you just shoot straight
at it and would go right that under why
it's arcing good catch there good cop
you have your moment dude dance so
basically we don't get a writing unless
we get spoilers thanks rules you are
yeah I keep the truly important things
from you figure out a good time to I'll
require you are doing the Lord's work
today alright guys so that is tales from
the comments section part yeah yeah
whatever saying they don't care
about you alright thank you very much
for watching tales from the comment
section hosted by yours truly this has
been tales from the conversation of Star
Wars Episode eighth last Jedi oh this is
solo we did a lot right
long yeah they don't care about you
alright so this is so long we might
actually break it up into a couple
videos maybe two or three that'd be a
lot of fun so you know stay tuned and
you'll keep those comments coming if you
like to see here you want some more
clear Gracie more you go punch that
or what
oh are you done punch it and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right yeah
okay Wow
what you cut me off and this is the
result cricket cricket to show
that it's not soothing it's boring as
you're never allowed to do this
again there we go no it's good in the
world oh my god it's still going this is
the literal worst
there's the last time I'll let you do
the outro I don't want to just cut you
off there's gonna be a fan uprising now
because of you and the crickets you
too
Hey